You ready to solve this uh solve this
dilemma, man? Yeah. Oh, I don't know if
I could solve it, man. I'm not I'm not
really uh I'm not the savior to all your
answers. But the taps for um verse 241
that you guys were talking about. Can
you pull up the taps to see what like
you know what the verse you know is
talking about? The verse is talking
about the Jews. No, I understand. Just
but just cuz I might be confused. I was
looking at the explanation of the verse
for myself and kind of like what the guy
was saying before. It was saying that it
is confirming the um it is confirming
the Quran to the people of this time.
But it is also Can you pull up the verse
again just so I can see it again? Cuz I
was just reading the taps uh just before
you put me on. Yeah. And it says um and
believe in what I have sent down
confirming that which is already with
you. So just the taps I was reading it
was saying to basically to believe in
the Quran to confirm uh with what is
already with you which is kind of like
what the guy was saying but you were
saying wrong so I'm just so so just to
be clear you agree with the past Muslim
that no I'm saying is confirming itself
I'm saying can you pull up the taps so
like you know we can read it together
like you know an explanation on the
verse. What do I need what do I what do
I need that for? I don't need that. The
verse is clear. I wouldn't say it's
clear because just what I read, you
know, it was okay. So, let's let's see
if it's clear or not. I mean, it's tough
if this isn't clear. It's okay. But it
says, "And believe in what I have sent
down." What was sent down? The Quran.
All right. Confirming that which is
already with you. So, the Quran is
confirming something else, right? It is.
It is confirming that the scriptures are
the word of God. Yes. No, it doesn't say
that. It doesn't say it's confirming
that the scriptures are the word of God.
Even though that's true, but what they
have what what they have with them
though, right? Yeah. So, it's not
confirming itself. It's confirming the
scriptures they have with them. Correct.
It's saying believe in what I sent down
to you. What was sent down? The Quran
confirming which what you already have.
So, meaning the Quran's confirming
something else, right? Not itself. It
is. So, you see how you see how this is
clear that we don't need any type of
explanations for this. very clear. But
I'll be honest and just like I said the
taps here that I read and that's why I
said you know if if we could pull it up
and if we could read it together but
just like the explanation that I was
reading from the internet is kind of
going with what the guy said. And I'm
not saying that I agree with him or I
disagree with him but I'm saying can we
read it together? We don't need to I
don't need to read a faulty explanation
if the verse is very clear. If there's
an explanation that goes against what
the verse says then the explanation is
false. Wouldn't you agree? But if
multiple people are saying the same
thing that I've read, are they all
lying? If if they go against what the
Quran says, then they're lying. Would
you not agree? But I'm saying what I'm
saying. You would agree with that,
Usman? If they're going against the
Quran? Yeah. If their explanation goes
against the Quran, are they right? I
mean, no. Obviously, no. Okay. So, if we
just looked at what the Quran says for
itself, if their explanation does not
match what we just read in the Quran,
Yeah, their explanation is irrelevant.
It's wrong. But the verse is saying, can
you pull out the verse again? Yep. And
it's saying, you know, believe what I
have sent down, what I what was sent
down. You know, what was the Quran?
That's right. Confirming the word of God
that was previous that the people had,
but they had it currently with them,
right? Cuz it says it's with them. It's
with them. Mhm. So, so the Torah, the
Gospel, the the Psalms, the writings of
the prophet, the Quran is confirming
that what they have, these scriptures
they have is true. It's the word of God.
Mhm. If anybody tries to explain this
verse any other way, they're liars cuz
the Quran verse is clear. But it's
confirming what they have for sure, but
it's also saying, "Believe what I have
sent down to you." That's correct.
That's correct. So according to the
verse, they have to believe not in just
their own scripture, but also in the new
scripture that's coming, which is the
Quran. They have to believe in it all.
Uh uh I I wouldn't I wouldn't disagree
with you. But what I would say to that
is
um in the jail that they did have just
as you know being a Muslim. It would be
hard for me to believe that that you
know Jesus was preaching that you know
he was the son of God and things like
that you know etc etc. Mhm. I I
understand because you're and you said
you the way you started that off was
perfect because you're a Muslim. Mhm.
You have this Islamic worldview. So
obviously the Quran goes against this
type of idea that Jesus is the son of
God, that he was crucified and rose
again for our sins, right? That his that
it's through his blood that we're
forgiven and stuff like that. The Quran
negates all of that type of teaching and
ide ideology. Mhm. So as a Muslim, you
you wouldn't be able to accept that
Jesus taught that because the Quran does
goes against that very clearly goes
against that. That's the dilemma because
when you look at what Jesus taught
because the way that you find this out
is to go back to see what Jesus actually
taught. When you see it, you see that he
says, "I'm the son of God. I came to
give my life as a ransom through my
blood that the that the covenant is
given for the forgiveness of sins."
That's what Jesus teaches. So, since the
Quran says that the teachings of Jesus
is true of Jesus, the Quran is false.
Can I So, I was just looking at some uh
Sorry, hold on. Let me pull my window
up. It's cuz I was looking at verses in
the Quran where Jesus is mentioned. My
background is a firefighter. My bad if
it's not. Yeah, it's uh just give us
Yeah. Uh so I was just um like reading
verses like uh looking how many times
Jesus was mentioned in the Quran. Mhm.
And um you know I saw things that like
um there will be a time where Jesus
where God will ask Jesus um let me see
if I can switch tabs real quick. No
don't don't do it. We can't see you and
we won't be able to hear you. But I I I
got you. Can you hear me? Try to come
back if you can. Yeah. That just messed
up his whole connection. Can you hear
me? Can you hear me? Can you hear me? I
know the verse you're talking about. 5
verse 116 where Allah asks did he tell
people to uh worship him and his mother
as gods besides Allah he's going to say
you know what's in my soul I don't know
what's in your soul you know and then
there's also uh verses that you know
that Jesus said to pray to Allah and and
things like that so it's hard for me to
kind of just see how when Jesus had the
in jail he would be preaching that um
you know that I am God and like uh I am
the son of God and things like that. You
want to know why? Because you're coming
at this from the wrong start. Okay.
You're starting out with the Muslim
perspective. But is it the start? No.
Okay. According to the you start with
the original. It's the original that you
start with. Like for example, for
Christians, right? And I would ridicule
a Christian who would say, "Oh, I just
read the New Testament. That's it." No,
you need the Old Testament, too, because
it's the Old Testament that brings the
understanding of what the New Testament
is talking about in the first place.
Okay? You know what I'm saying? You
can't neglect the New the Old Testament.
You need it. Jesus quoted it. Paul
quoted it. Peter and all them, they
appealed to it all the time. So, the
same way the Quran is consistently
appealing to the previous scriptures
just like the New Testament appeals to
the Old Testament, right? So you start
there with the previous scriptures. Go
look and see what Jesus actually taught.
Then you'll be able to get the full
perspective, a complete and true
perspective on who Jesus was, what he
taught, how he practiced his religion.
And then you'll see if Muhammad was a
true prophet or not. But with that being
said, if if I do go back to the to the
previous books and I do and I do read,
you know, the verse where it says um not
like I'm not quoting, but where it does
say Jesus is God. How could I use that
as a confirmation when my book says that
that's not the case? And that's the
dilemma. That's the dilemma. That's the
dilemma. The dilemma is is that the
Quran points you to the previous
scriptures. But when you go to the
previous scriptures, it says Jesus is
God. Jesus died for our sins. The Quran
goes against those teachings. So it's
confirming a scripture. It's confirming
teachings. Yeah. That it contradicts at
the same time. That's why the Quran is
false. smile. But I would say it's not
contradicting because the the scripture
that that God would have revealed would
have is what I'm trying to say is that
it would have never said that you know
um Jesus How do you know? See, I I I
know that you're saying this as a
Muslim. I I need I'm challenging your
thinking. Use critical thinking skills.
Okay. If you wanted to know what Moses
actually taught Yeah. where would you
go? You probably wouldn't get like the
best description in the Quran, but I
feel like you could still get, you know,
descriptions of Moses in the Quran.
Where would you go if you wanted to
learn from Moses firsthand, what he
actually taught? That would be the
Torah. Now, very good. It'll be the
Torah. Okay. Where would you go if you
wanted to see what Jesus himself taught?
Not what somebody's telling you what he
said, but what Jesus taught? Where would
you go? Um, you'd have to go to the
Bible. No, you have to go to the Bible.
Yeah. So, but that's just because
there's not really like the most um
these are these are the scriptures that
the Quran points to. Yeah. So, when you
when you want to know what they actually
Can I Can I say something? These are the
scriptures that the Quran points to. But
what I'm kind of trying to say is that
these current scriptures really really
wouldn't go along with the Quran because
the Quran says that Jesus didn't say
these things. So, how can I go back to
these scriptures if I'm not too sure
what what in it is, you know, from my
point of view like the truth and like
what isn't the truth? Let me show you
what the Quran tells you to do. Okay? Go
ahead and read that verse for me. So,
you if if you are in doubt, oh Muhammad,
about that which have had which we have
revealed to you, then ask sorry, it's
kind of small. Then ask those who have
been reading the scripture before you.
The truth has certainly come to to you
from your Lord. So never among the
doubters. So if you are questioning the
Quran, what does the Quran tell you even
as a Muslim to Muhammad that he's
supposed to do? Where do you go? It
says, "Then ask those who have been
reading the scripture before you." So
what is the ultimate judge on what is
true or not based on this verse? So but
that's my whole point. I don't think if
Muhammad went to people back then to ask
about the scriptures, at least to the
people he knew, I don't I I but I could
be wrong, but I don't think they would
be telling him that, you know, Jesus is
God. My friend, read the read the verse
again. What is Muhammad supposed to do
if he's questioning the Quran or
anybody's questioning the Quran? What
are you supposed to do? You go to the
people of the scripture. But but that's
but that's what I'm trying to say. What?
So, hold on. Hold on just a second.
Okay. According to the verse, what is
the thing that determines the truth?
According to this verse and whether the
Quran's telling the truth, whether the
Quran's telling the truth, uh then ask
those who have been reading the
scripture before you. So whether or not
the script the Quran lines up with the
previous scriptures judges whether or
not the Quran is true or false, right?
I'm sorry. Can you say that one more
time? So notice how it says that if
Muhammad is is questioning the Quran,
Mhm.
then he has to go to the previous
scriptures. Mhm. And therefore, if he
went to the previous scriptures, he'll
find that the Quran's in line with them
and then therefore would know would have
no doubt in the Quran because he'll see
that the Quran lines up with the
previous scripture. Now let's do the
reverse. If he goes back to the previous
scripture, he's doubting the Quran, he
goes checks with the previous scriptures
and he sees that the Quran does not
match what they what the scriptures say,
then he'll have reason to doubt the
Quran. Right. Yes. So, this means that
it's the previous scriptures that's the
judge on whether or not the Quran is
true. If the Quran doesn't line up with
the previous scripture, the Quran is
false. and and I I wouldn't agree with
you. But what I'm trying to say is that
if Muhammad went to go inquire about the
previous scripture, I personally don't
think he would be reading the injil
where Jesus is preaching that he is God
and that he is the son of God because
because according to the Quran, Jesus
prayed to Allah. So then that would just
mean that the Quran is wrong if it
doesn't match up with the right. How so?
Would you say would you say that you're
reading the same nil that that um Jesus
preached to the people today? Yep. Well,
then I then I guess you know that would
just be you know where our dis where our
disagreement uh you know would would
come. Why would you disagree with that?
Because um just from you know the Old
Testament cuz uh the the Old Test I mean
the New Testament you know came around
if I'm not mistaken centuries later.
Nope. It's in the first century.
We have copies. We have copies that come
from centuries later. But the New
Testament was written in the first
century. And And how many years, you
know, after, you know, Jesus and
Muhammad like was that after Jesus? You
have within uh like 30 40 years of his
of of him ascending to heaven at the New
Testament was being written down. Can I
ask you something, bro? Just cuz you're
a pretty smart guy. Um, so I as she I
asked a lot of questions and it was
saying something about like the council
of Na. The council of Na had nothing to
do with the Bible. It had to do with the
church knocking off this heresy of
Aryanism. This guy named Aras was going
against the deity of Christ. And so the
church bishops got together. They had
this council to refute him with the
scripture and to further articulate and
establish the Christian doctrine on the
deity of Christ. So So I'm not So cuz
Tabby was saying something about how
like the church in Nia like established
an official book. Is that true or not?
No. Okay. Well, maybe Chad GBT was just
[__] I'm not here to argue. I'm just
here to really just ask you. I have
another question though. Hold on though,
cuz this is getting away from what we're
talking about. My fault. My fault. Okay.
Okay. So, why would you disagree that I
don't have that I have the teachings of
Jesus? Why would you disagree with that?
Um, just because, you know, I was born
Muslim and the Quran says that, you
know, Allah do not say Allah was beget
or or begotten. What does that have to
do with the the gospel? The Quran is not
the gospel. How do you know that I do
not have the gospel that Jesus was
preaching? In the gospel, does it not
say that, you know, Jesus is God? Yeah.
So, you know, just in the Quran that I
read, it would say something different.
Brother, I'm asking you to think again.
Yes. Think. I'm thinking. How do you
know that what I have is not what Jesus
was preaching? The Quran comes 600 years
after Jesus. It's not an authority on
what Jesus said. How do you know that
what I have is not what Jesus was
preaching? I mean, but if you're saying
that I can't use the Quran as my source,
I I would say that's not really fair
because that is my source. You know
what? You're right. That's perfectly
fine. You know what? Actually, you don't
have what Muhammad was actually
preaching. You don't What do you mean by
that? I'm sorry. You don't have what
Muhammad was going around reciting. The
Quran that you have is not the same
Quran that Muhammad was going around
reciting. If I'm not mistaken, don't
they have like a Quran? I forgotten what
country that like dates to like right
around the time Muhammad was alive. No,
it's like it's not a Quran. It's only a
couple of pages. Okay. So, so what Quran
would you say we're reciting? A false
Quran. I think that probably Usma made
up or something. And where do you get
that from? Well, I see that the Quran
teaches that Allah doesn't beget. But
the Bible says that the father begget
his son and sent him into the world. So,
I know that that's not the Quran that
Muhammad was reciting cuz Muhammad would
have been preaching a message that lines
up with the Bible. And can you prove to
me that the Quran is false? That this is
Yeah, because Yeah. The Quran says that
Allah doesn't begget. It says Jesus is
not the son of God. Jesus says
Jesus is the son of God and that the
father does beget. So, that's how I know
that the Quran is false. The Quran never
the Quran never really said Allah
doesn't begget. So, but then I could use
that same logic with the Bible then
know, couldn't
I? Are you upset or something? I'm
bewildered. Not upset. What What are you
bewildered about, though? What did I say
that? What did I say that didn't make
any sense? Oh, no. What you said made
purpose sense? What? What? What I'm
bewildered by is that you said it as if
you didn't get what you just said. What
do you mean? Yet, you just said that you
can you can just use that same logic
with the Bible then, can't you? Because
you because That show that shows that
you that shows that you don't even know
what just happened. No, cuz you just
told me that you don't believe in the
Quran because of what it said and I
said, "Can I not use that same logic for
the Bible?" It's what you've been using.
That's been your logic. Don't you get
it? You've been saying that. That's been
your point. I just reversed it on you.
And you don't even know that I did it.
And you and you did and you didn't think
that my point was good because you're
asking for proof. And if my proof is,
well, the it doesn't agree with the
Bible, so I know the Quran never really
said that. It couldn't have said it. It
disagrees with the Bible. You didn't
take that as proof. You didn't think
that that was a sufficient answer. But
that's the logic you're using and you
don't even get it. I'm using logic based
on the Quran because it's what I know. I
know. I'm not trying to put It's not
like I'm trying to play you or anything.
I'm just using the logic. I got you.
Look, look, study some more, man. Keep
reading. No. Did I not answer your
question though? Usman, I'm telling you
this as a from a brother in humanity to
another brother in humanity. Okay.
Listen to me carefully. Okay. Cuz I'm
not your enemy. As you can see, I'm not
your enemy. I don't hate you. You called
me You called me an idiot last time.
Yeah, you're I'm And I don't I I got to
stand by. I'm sorry. You um You're But I
answered everything you said, though.
You're right. You did. You're displaying
idiocy. Please tell me you Well, how
about this? Re-watch this and then see
if you sound good and logical. See it.
I'm trying to give you something. I want
to give you some advice. Go study. Okay.
Read both the Quran. Keep reading the
Quran. Okay. Read the Bible. Okay.
Study. But you don't believe in the
Quran. Then come talk to me. But you
don't but you don't read the Quran.
Anything in the Quran, you refuse. Now
Now you're manifesting. Now you're
manifesting. You are not welcome back
because you are too illiterate and too
illogical to talk to me. Go study. You
will not be back. You're not welcome
back. You're too dumb. Take care of
yourself. You're too dumb. What do I
need to study? You're too dumb, bro.
Can't even humbly take advice. That's
when you become an idiot to me. You
don't become No, you don't become an
idiot when if you're humbly, you know,
illogical. I mean, at least to me, I I I
won't call you an idiot if you're humbly
illogical. But once you demonstrate that
you're not humble and you're still
stupid, that's when you become an idiot.
That's when you are idiotic. When you
begin to manifest. Praise the Lord. We
got 4,000 people right here watching
here on YouTube. Guys, everybody hit
that like button. All 4,000 of you guys,
you guys are enjoying the conversation.
If you guys are new here, go ahead and
subscribe. We do these type of
conversations all the time, and you see
that um I deal with all kinds of
different characters. So, go ahead and
subscribe. Make sure you guys hit the
like button. support the stream. Let the
stream blow up more than it already has.
But we got 4,000 people in here watching
Muslims get crushed on the Islamic
dilemma that Muhammad Hijab tried to
refute and did an abysmal job. Abysmal.
I never use that word in my everyday
language, by the way. He did horrible.
Okay. It was horrible.